if you're watching this right now
anybody at home don't be sorry
everything happens happens for a reason
man when you follow your heart you
always win no matter what it is lately
I'm working at combating depression
combating super attempts people that
want to commit
combat and bullying
I'm a designer I'm a lifestyle curator
I'm just big on that like emotional
intelligence being addicted to
self-improvement like that's my thing on
it like learning how to surrender
I know I'm so great but at the same time
I'm only like a little piece on the
board taking myself out of the equation
and looking at how we affect each other
as a whole because when I say I'm great
we great
in order for me to see greatness as
somebody else I got to see greatness in
myself I operate out of the spirit of
love
everything I do out of love even if you
play I'm gonna just love you to death
but it's all love with me without being
tested you never know that your true
strength or your true Inner Strength
whether it be psychologically whether it
be mentally or physically or emotionally
you gotta tense yourself and always push
yourself so you know I'm truly strong
you really are I always been a
sacrificial lamb and I ain't even
playing victim I know I'm more to deal
with I know I don't communicate for fear
of people judging me or fulfilled you
taking my vulnerability and using
against me I don't get close to people
fulfill you taking my loyalty and using
against me because
I could be honest with you every time I
went to jail it was for somebody else
every time I went to prison was the best
time it was the best thing because I
always got greater through my isolation
I learned it through isolation you you
elevate when you isolate you elevate
cause you had one with yourself you in
tune with yourself
you're not being openly stimulated with
social media you're not none of that you
just really just with yourself and that
Oneness
you become god-like in a sense I live
life at an accelerator pace and I did
have positive male reinforcement in my
life even though a lot of the males in
my life made a lot of the wrong
decisions but the intentions was pure
because that's all they knew they had no
choice but that and like I say big
brother don't get it twisted I'm not
perfect I make mistakes every day I
break down I get angry I do all of that
everybody do that but I have ways of
dealing with it let's just say this
Kevin Gates says things that people are
afraid to say doing better than what I
used to be doing because it's a
continuous charity like it ain't never
gonna stop like it don't I might have a
bad day tomorrow I might say I ain't go
crazy right but we still gonna keep
going like our 10 people healing is a
journey if you don't just heal in one
session
yeah you gotta always put in the work
like I ain't supposed to be sitting here
keep myself inventory while I'm talking
to you but I do that because I got to
because I'm human and I don't judge
people because I know I ain't got no
regular judge nobody we just think best
of ourselves but I had made a bottle of
myself I never do no more negative
self-talk I never doubt myself beat
myself up for past mistakes and what's
been helping me when I do myself
inventory checks like any mistake like
you ever made a mistake and you think
back in kind of cringe like man I should
dig I go back and forgive myself yeah
because I like the exhibit emotional
intelligence with anything that I'm
dealing with in life okay yeah I like
emotional intelligence because I was
just reading that every time we have an
emotion it's related to a chemical
release in our body that causes that
emotion that we're experiencing at the
time so instead of asking me why am I
feeling like this how I'm feeling why am
I experiencing this emotion it helps you
navigate emotional intelligence
like if somebody disrespect me did he
really disrespect me
was it an imminent threat what morals or
principles did I compromise by him doing
what he did like I asked myself why was
it triggering is it something that
happened
is it a past traumatic reaction as
opposed to a response so it's just about
emotional intelligence for me keeping
itself inventory because a lot of times
we don't understand
we don't understand Fiji we don't
understand that we don't understand the
emotional detox and I'm not going to say
I let bad experiences frame me
like I learned from somebody that don't
change who you are change who you good
to but my thing is I just do it in a
broader Spectrum now so I don't hone in
on just one individual but if I I'd have
had people around me that I'd have gave
them the game
I like really gave him the game
and like I'm super proud of them
whatever whatever but sometimes some
people could love you so much
they could love you so much
that their pure existence will be
shattered
if you don't disappear
they got people like that like they can
love you so much and relate everything
you do so much but by you still existing
it shatters who they want to be
and it's been like that my whole life in
my neighborhood not the cop been in the
streets my whole life so I got a bunch
of like people that y'all watch me do
these things in the streets and emulated
me and everything that y'all do from
accident to walk talk everything when I
cried three four times a day yeah I
don't care I haven't been through so
much paraphragmatic experience that we
suppress as men we have to be so tough
all the time that we never release the
years it is I've been through the worst
of the worst you know because I always
looked at having a family like winning
right that's how I always looked at that
like wife children that's winning to me
like having a million multiple females
that were never winning to me that's the
person that always been was
family and children like that's how I
was raised kind of old-fashioned so
even in my situationships I end up this
is my first time saying this I'm just
saying it because I'm in front of you
even with a woman that I'm dealing with
I kind of deal well as if like
she my significant other my partner like
like because that's when I was looking
for that love in all the wrong places
before I started putting that love back
into myself
it's so easy for me to pour into other
people and when I do finally point on
myself I kind of feel wrong for doing so
one of the biggest things about me I
learned how to just laugh at myself
because I used to operate out of the
field what people think about me or what
they gonna say I like carry your credit
and not just laugh at myself now I just
be afraid to make mistakes in front of
people
try to try to make every answer sound
politically correct and I no man I'm
living life
people are perfect people are people
people feel real emotions they have real
thoughts it's okay to have fun it's okay
to loosen up it's okay to get if I was
living
um you don't take a chance you ain't had
a chance you're making a plan to lose
right took in advance to pay them back I
made it in advance to move I know how to
stand and greet a man whenever he walk
in the room because it makes me feel
good to give another man that respect
the world isn't as it is it's SBC is as
we see we are reflections of one another
your spirit is already holding right out
of five billion sperms you was the one
that made it and if you stop evolving
then you die
yeah you got to keep growing you got to
keep growing if you stay staging you you
stop growing and anything not growing is
dead
when you leave the only thing that be
left the only thing left that you leave
behind is your name so I'd rather a good
name over multiple riches and things of
that nature
best things in life are really free it's
just it's once we change our perspective
that's when Miracles really start to
happen in our lives
[Music]